mais ça fait plusieurs semaines que
voilà il y a des beaucoup d'agences qui
travaillent sur ces photos des gens le
cherchent l'attendent et ça a fini par
arriver la semaine dernière c'est quoi
c'est une pas par hasard ou c'est les
photos c'est des photos prises à la avec
son accord d'accord très bien aussi ça
et il va comment faire Palmade c'est
quoi les infos les photos montrent un
homme qui a l'air d'aller un peu mieux
physiquement on va aller voir dans un
instant oui c'est quelqu'un qui
effectivement encore une fois il est pas
question de dire que Pierre Palmade
enfin on est pas là pour expliquer tout
ce qui tout ce qui s'est passé avant
c'est quelqu'un qui est dans un
processus dans une cure de
désintoxication son processus se termine
le 24 avril donc à la fin de la semaine
et là ils vont étudier avec la justice
quelle est la suite donc c'est quelqu'un
qui est en train de se soigner
ça c'est des discussions qui sont en
cours avec son avocate et la justice
c'est vrai que tous ces proches ont
lâché ou pas ah bah visiblement oui il y
a personne de ce que moi j'ai pu
comprendre il y a que deux personnes qui
ont essayé d'aller le voir qui sont son
attachés de presse et son ancien
producteur et ces gens-là se sont fait
et conduire poliment par la sécurité de
l'hôpital après personne n'a essayé
d'aller le voir encore une fois ça
sentait donc elle s'est améliorée dans
ce qu'on voit oui bah de toute façon dès
le dès le 12 février on savait qu'il
était tiré d'affaires en revanche ce qui
a été pris en charge par la santé par
enfin c'est par le personnel médical
c'est sortir Pierre Palmade de ses
addictions donc la cocaïne et la 3 MMC
on va revenir sur l'article vous allez
voir les informations qu'on a dedans oui
Gilles oui il y a une phrase incroyable
dans l'article
un moment c'est le le la déclaration
qu'il fait à sa sœur où il lui dit on va
revenir dessus on va revenir dessus
sur les proches vous dites que Carole
Bouquet est une des rares après l'avoir
lâché j'espère que vous avez des vrais
infos parce que c'est quand même
encore une fois c'est ceux qui ne l'ont
pas condamné c'est pas un charlot
et sa femme on dit c'est terminé on sait
que Michel Laroque a dit c'est terminé
car le bouquet qui a toujours été proche
mais c'est pas exprimé n'arrête pas
répondu au sollicitations médiatiques
pour dire je le je le condamne mais en
tout cas elle a voilà elle a un discours
assez alors on va revenir sur ce qu'il y
a dans l'article alors vous dites il n'y
a aucun policier en faction devant sa
chambre d'hôpital au service
addictologie de l'hôpital Paul Brousse
de Villejuif donc il y a pas de il doit
prendre des médicaments de substitution
il est sous surveillance médicale
constante
toute personne en cure de
désintoxication il n'a pas le revisite
donc vous l'avez dit son ancien
producteur et son attaché de presse ont
été tous les deux refoulés poliment par
les services de sécurité de
l'établissement pourquoi il n'a pas le
revisite ça c'est ce qui a été
conclure entre son avocate et l'hôpital
que la chaîne Gulli à disposition au
Kremlin-Bicêtre ils ont estimé au tout
début que fallait fallait faire
attention en fait parce que il savait
pas Gulli donc il regardait les Dragon
Ball Z
on sait pas en tout cas c'est la seule
chaîne non mais c'est incroyable c'est
une info alors il faut dire que
proche de Pierre Palin en tout cas
bouscule pas pour aller le voir mais
forcément c'est compliqué puisqu'ils
n'ont pas le droit visite claire la
seule sœur avec qui il était en contact
et qui gérait ses affaires aurait claqué
la porte de l'hôpital deux jours après
l'accident le 12 février dernier
lorsqu'elle a entendu son frère Pierre
prononcer une phrase que vous dévoilez
donc Paris Match ce qui montre son sa
totale inconscience alors justement deux
jours après cette phrase c'est vrai
qu'elle est incroyable dis donc elle va
valoir cher ma première interview c'est
total inconscience de que voilà encore
une fois on sait que le 11 12 février il
comprend pas enfin c'est il se
positionne au tout départ comme une
victime il est victime de la drogue ce
qui lui arrive c'est très dur et donc il
met du temps ce qui est horrible dans
cette phrase c'est que peut-être que
dans 10 ans
et ce sera la phrase ce sera le cas en
fait ça voudra dire cette première
interview parce que c'est fini et ce
sera comme ça malheureusement
ou alors il comprend que peut-être le
silence est la meilleure interview de
Pierre Palmade peut-être oui mais en
tout cas il y a des vrais révélations
c'est incroyable sa mère qui réside à
Bordeaux n'a pas pris le train pour
venir rendre à sa mère est totalement
absente de cette affaire depuis le 10
février sa mère elle pourrait venir le
visiter la laisser rentrer sa mère non
techniquement oui la famille sont les
seules personnes a priori qui compte
plus la facilité d'accès et pour
l'instant ça va maman elle n'est jamais
une manière aussi de non pas de news en
tout cas la pas estimé utile de prendre
le train pour aller voir son fils donc
comme vous l'avez dit il vous dit qu'il
a été lâché par Muriel Robin et sa femme
Anne par Michel Laroque qui peut encore
compter
précisé que normalement les passions
restent deux semaines dans ce service
mais Pierre palmades on est déjà sa
sixième semaine pourquoi Pierre Palmade
il a fait 6 semaines alors que les
autres font deux semaines pour parce que
Pierre Palmade est sous contrôle
judiciaire un contrôle judiciaire très
strict qui a été établi entre la juge et
son avocate avec beaucoup de choses
qu'il ne peut pas faire d'accord et
notamment il doit rester dans une
structure médicalisée sous surveillance
médicale et donc il a été convenu que ce
protocole 1 durerait six semaines après
encore une fois on va voir ce qu'on fait
ensuite alors comme vous l'avez dit que
va-t-il se passer lundi on va vous dire
parce que lundi c'est une journée
importante après deux mois et demi passe
à l'hôpital il pourrait quitter
l'hôpital dès lundi prochain il devrait
donc avoir un nouveau contrôle
judiciaire c'est ça en attendant la date
fatidique de son procès son contrôle
judiciaire actuel ne lui permet pas de
retourner dans sa maison il interdiction
de quitter l'Île-de-France donc il
pourrait soit aller dans son appartement
dans le troisième arrondissement de
Paris soit aller chez l'une de ses sœurs
qui pourraient bien l'accueillir ou
alors aller dans un autre centre de
soins type voilà un centre de
désintoxication un autre hôpital qui
serait prêt à l'hôpital et on attend en
fait la décision exactement
on apprend aussi et ça c'est les
révélations incroyables que vous faites
dans Paris Match on apprend aussi que
l'accident était limite inévitable
contenu de sa récente descente aux
enfers vous revenez également vous
renouveler là-dessus et raconter que fin
2022 la situation était déjà devenue
très problématique fin 2022 le tournage
de la fine équipe émission commentaire à
palmat par France Télévision c'est sur
France 2
vit vivre au naufrage sont cette
capitaine du bateau pierre arrive en
Tarn ne reconnaît pas ses invités
s'enferme avec
sambout
qui était son compagnon alors avec son
bout dans sa loge et son plus sont plus
déconnectés que jamais c'est qui sans
vous sans vous c'est c'était son
compagnon malheureusement de ton sexe de
soirée glauque et c'était celui qui le
piquait mieux il l'avait dit d'ailleurs
que les orteils des marques
donc lui c'est lui qui le pitié et il
est où ce ben s'il a été entendu par la
police et d'accord
c'est un des deux qui était dans la
voiture
il avait interdiction de le voir il
était dans la voiture le jour de
l'accident alors donc oui donc on
apprend ça quoi donc il était raconté ça
veut dire que la France était donc en
récidive parce qu'il avait pas le droit
de le voir effectivement mais il est
libre la promotion vous dites tourne au
fiasco lorsque après son passage à
l'antenne d'une station de radio
parisienne un sachet de cocaïne et
découvert dans les toilettes Palma dans
pochera 170000 euros pour sa calamité
l'histoire c'est qu'il a il a en panique
parce que il a plus de thunes il a
besoin d'argent parce que ça coûte très
cher d'avoir de se fournir en trois MMC
et en Cook et donc effectivement il a
peur que la promotion de l'émission
s'arrêtant qu'il ne touche pas le cachet
qui lui était promis c'était chez vous
maintenant
vous savez qu'il y avait de la cocaïne
qui avait été retrouvé dans les
toilettes alors pour être honnête j'ai
reçu pierre pour le la feniki 2 c'est ça
et il était venu sur RFM répondre à des
questions il était pas très en forme du
tout à tel point que j'ai demandé à ne
pas
de Maurice confie ce proche il aime être
un homme public il a toujours vécu ainsi
il n'est pas du genre à quitter la scène
en toute discrétion il va avoir du mal à
comprendre que sa carrière est terminée
même bincent quota a fini par admettre
que parfois le silence et la meilleure
des options c'est-à-dire en fait lui
c'est à dire que les rares personnes qui
parlent de lui encore une fois il y a
personne qui a envie de le défendre donc
j'ai pas d'autres arguments à écrire
puisque il y a personne qui me dit moi
je pense qu'il va qu'il faut qu'il
revienne je pense que ça va lui faire du
bien personne ne me parle de ça les gens
quand je les sollicite je me prends
beaucoup de portes donc ceux qui
effectivement qui sont un petit peu
écœurés de ce qui de ce qui s'est passé
ont cet aspect on cette vision des
choses ouais Valérie j'ai un proche de
Pierre Palmade qui est en train de
m'écrire donc je citerai pas son nom
mais il n'explique qu'il a été opéré
deux fois
des artères après l'AVC il m'explique
également que son état était vraiment
sérieux qu'il est contrairement à ce qui
est dit dans l'article enfin au tout
début en février qu'il était aujourd'hui
extrêmement mal pour la famille
il dit il dit également que il apprenne
normalement il va aller en cure longue
donc voilà et que effectivement il y
avait une de ces sœurs qui était fâchée
mais que ses sœurs sont proches de lui
et qu'il souhaitaient aller à Bordeaux
près de sa maman mais qu'il n'a pas le
droit de quitter l'Île-de-France et que
donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles il ne va pas près de sa maman
voilà et que la plupart de ses proches
ce qu'il appelle la personne en tout cas
appelle les vrais proches de s'expriment
pas justement par respect et pour les
familles et pour la faire
de la famille qui a été touché on peut
peut-être donner des nouvelles j'ai eu
mettre bâtic donc la jeune femme qui a
qui a perdu son bébé c'est très
difficile et l'enfant qui est retourné à
l'école il est extrêmement faible il est
bien loin évidemment d'aller bien et de
reprendre une scolarité normale c'est
difficile quant au conducteur de 40 ans
qui a été blessé multi opéré toucher au
pied au genou notamment il est toujours
hospitalisé et la réhabilitation ça ça
le fait qu'il retrouve la santé sera
étaléatoire et sera très très long alors
là on va voir les photos de de Paris
Match révélé par Paris Match on va voir
ça tout de suite alors voilà donc voilà
donc ça c'est quoi c'est des officiers
de sécurité c'est de la sécurité de
l'hôpital qui l'accompagne pour pas
qu'il soit opportuné par des autres par
d'autres par d'autres patients d'accord
donc c'est c'est quoi il fait des il
fait des quoi tous les jours merci vous
aviez l'info comme quoi il voilà il
savait juste qu'il était là et on a on
espérait un jour comment ça se passe
pour noter les spectateurs ça c'est quoi
c'est un photographe qui planque
d'accord je pense que toutes les agences
parisiennes travaillent sur pierre
palades oui parce que c'est une histoire
qui a passionné les gens et voilà oui
c'est il y a beaucoup de les gens sont
en quête d'image donc Gilles ça se passe
c'est ça donc vous racontez aussi il a
fait trois hôpitaux là il est à
Villejuif et effectivement il sort alors
on voit un moment ils regardent ils
regardent l'objectif peut-être qu'il
sent qu'il y a des photographes qui sont
cachés mais effectivement il y avait
plusieurs mois on m'a dit qu'il y avait
plusieurs dizaines de paparazzi qui
étaient sur la piste de Palmade parce
que on cherchait il cherchait tous à
avoir ses photos exclusives ça c'est
évidemment Val très cher qu'elles
veulent combien ces photos comme ça
genre dizaines de milliers d'euros
m'attendais c'est à dire combien
confirmé désolé
je pense que c'est tout ça et du
fantasme pour le coup vous êtes sûr ah
oui je suis sûr que c'est du coup c'est
sûr même un très bons spectateurs qui
voient les photos qu'est-ce qu'elles
amènent les photos en fait là ça montre
quelqu'un qui qui va qui va bien en fait
voilà qui revient c'est un peu c'est un
peu bizarre de voir ça en fait on l'a
pas revu depuis la fine équipe parce que
si on l'avait aperçu à la sortie du
tribunal quelques quelques secondes mais
voilà c'est pas s'il va bien on voit
bien qu'il marche
ouais alors logiquement comment il est
quand même l'histoire de l'AVC sur
lequel moi je ne suis pas revenu mais
effectivement il a une période vraiment
il était pas bien il était en fauteuil
roulant enfin voilà il y a quand même il
y avait qui est passé par des par des
épisodes de santé extrêmement compliqué
alors il y a une personne qui me dit que
c'est entre 4000 et 7000 euros une amie
Sophie qui me dit entre 4000 et 7000
euros les photos c'est pour le coup je
me sens pas bien
tu nous disais tout à l'heure et
incroyable il pense qu'il pourra
remonter sur scène mais oui Bertrand
Cantat est bien remonté sur scène après
avoir tué Marie Trintignant donc lui
pour lui il peut remonter sur l'artiste
a besoin parfois de l'amour du public
pour pour acheter une forme de
rédemption moi je cautionne pas du tout
mais en tout cas il y a il y a eu cette
il y a eu cette pensée là après les
choses évoluent est-ce qu'il a essayé
c'est ça la question que tout le monde
se pose il a essayé de rentrer en
contact avec la famille des victimes ou
les victimes ou pas du tout le premier
communiqué que fait Hélène la sœur avec
qui il était fâché elle lui explique
quand même que il certes il va pas bien
mais il y a une famille détruite donc là
il faut peut-être penser à cette famille
après je pense pas qu'ils sont en train
en contact est-ce que maintenant qu'il a
son portable etc peut-être est-ce qu'il
a été le coup du portable il a le droit
à un téléphone portable mais c'est
pareil le protocole a été fait de
manière à ce que
on lui conseille vivement de ne parler
qu'avec son avocate d'accord donc il est
pas censé téléphoner à la terre entière
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il le fait pas
parce que sinon ça aurait fini par
circuler mais non il a un téléphone
portable parce qu'encore une fois il est
libre mais il a un contrôle judiciaire
donc il peut pas faire tout ce qu'il
veut est-ce que
quelqu'un qui est sous contrôle visière
ce qui peut être mis sur écoute je sais
pas ça ce qu'on peut
utile pour l'enquête il faudrait que
l'enquête nécessite qu'il soit écouté en
permanence hors effectivement ces coups
de fil avec son avocat ça ne peut pas
l'être d'accord avec du domaine
confidentiel ça crée parfois des
scandales voilà mais ça c'est la
relation de confidentialité ce qui est
frappant dans l'article aussi c'est le
fait que ça vie soit extrêmement scandé
reparler fixe je crois que dans le ça
c'est le pur ils essaient de lui
redonner oui très normal ça c'est le
protocole de pour toute personne en cure
en fait et on me dit moi que ça pourrait
être éventuellement dans une clinique
privée pour plusieurs mois
encore une fois c'est ça en avocate qui
présente des plans voilà ce que moi j'ai
comme proposition voilà ce que j'ai
comme accueil possible voilà ce que
telle personne me dit la famille j'ai
cette ce centre de soins cet hôpital et
c'est le juge qui décide avec l'avocate
de qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que la
prochaine étape ça va être le procès un
jour il va y avoir un procès quand même
c'est de quelque chose qui va arriver
donc d'ici là bah il faut réfléchir à ce
qu'on fait de Pierre Palmade en tout cas
il y a peu de chances qu'on le voit
libérer rentrant chez lui il y a
toujours Sylvie qui a des infos apparent
qui me dit qui vaillent sur moi aller à
monter vidéo clinique privée c'est ça
voilà je voulais pas te donner dedans il
y a deux trois cliniques privées dont
celle-là qui sont spécialisés notamment
pour les gens connus qui ont des
problèmes où psychiatriques ou liés à
des addictions comme la drogue et qui
peuvent aller dans un environnement
privilégié au calme voilà c'est une
possibilité ce qu'on appelle ensemble
combien de semaines de mois de sevrage
sans prendre de cocaïne il le sera
plutôt il sera sauvé on peut dire il
n'aura plus envie d'en prendre croyais
là ce qu'on a jamais sauvé de ce genre
de ça sert à rien si parce que quand
même il a il a des choses qui sont mises
en place pour pour qu'il s'en sortent
mais le contrôle judiciaire il traîne
jusqu'au 10 août pour l'instant
dites-moi maintenant c'est quoi la suite
pour Pierre Palmade
moi je pense que la suite c'est le
silence l'oubli le mea culpa un jour
voilà mais je peux pas le savoir pour
lui dans son quotidien c'est quoi donc à
partir de lundi c'est la même vie
monacale
jusqu'à ce que la justice que je décide
que il est tiré d'affaires médicalement
parlant voilà et là après il y aura le
pouvoir étudier
d'accord donc là
ça prendra du temps il lui faut un
environnement médicalisé donc
effectivement plusieurs mois de repos et
de cure dans une clinique spécialisée ça
semble la solution que son avocate
pourrait présenter à la juge et que la
juge qui souhaite quand même
l'apaisement dans cette affaire
pourraient accepter parce qu'il faut
quand même un jour qui raconte ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi est-ce que sa
voiture
a tout d'un coup fait une embardée sur
la gauche